let me ask you a question what do con
men do con men con
people what do scammers do
scammers come up with scams donald trump
despite losing the presidency
is going to go out with one last scam on
the way out
donald trump's campaign has started to
send fundraising emails
urgent fundraising emails saying to
supporters
donate to us to pay for recounts
to pay for the legal fight to show that
we really won
to pay for voter fraud lawsuits but if
you look at the fine print of those
emails asking for money
they say that anywhere from 50 to 60
percent of your donation
by your i don't think anybody in my
audience is donating but
yours in trump's donations 50 to 60
percent of your donations
meant to fight the results and pay for
recounts and go to court
they actually will go to paying off
trump's debt debt is a major problem for
trump personally
business-wise and apparently
campaign-wise and one such fundraising
email actually says
50 of each contribution to be designated
towards trump's 2020 general election
account for general
election debt retirement until such debt
is retired money beyond that
will go to the recount account there is
always a grift there is always a scam
a separate trump email went out asking
for money
for the trump make america great again
committee and that one says
yeah yeah yeah you're donating here in
order to fight you know we got to keep
trump we got to fight it
but 60 of your money is going to go to
debt it's not actually clear how much
debt trump's campaign
has and in all seriousness putting the
campaign debt grift aside for a moment
imagine being so gullible that you get
conned into donating money to get this
billionaire cash for what are completely
bogus legal battles like imagine that a
hundred percent of the money actually
went to the legal battle
as opposed to only half of it that is
also a con job there are plenty of
people including folks on fixed incomes
who have been tricked by this and
they're donating their hard-earned money
that they can't even really afford to
donate
thinking maybe my donation will get
pennsylvania back
for trump maybe my donation will get
nevada back
uh or arizona back for the mango menace
maybe tangerine
can take back some other state and they
can't even afford it
and on top of the 50 to 60 percent of
their donations
uh um that on top of the fact that
50 to 60 of their donations won't even
go to that
they go merely to trying to help trump
pay down
debt and it actually raises real
questions of you know we've been saying
trump won't concede
because of his ego because of his
narcissism he's going to fight it and
he's going to maybe do rallies demanding
recounts and all this stuff
he's delusional he can't admit defeat
defeat that could be part of it
but the other part of it could be maybe
trump realizes
i'm out but i've got to pay down some of
this debt
let me bamboozle my followers into
donating money and i'll take half of it
and just use it to pay down debt
it's probably a combination of both um
but
the the grift is real and there is
always one more grift
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
um we are going to talk about the polls
now i'm still putting together the final
data
but again there is this idea the polls
totally failed the reality once again
is that looking at averages of polls
the polls were about as accurate as they
always are
you just have to understand polling to
do it
i will not be issuing a defense of the
polling industry by any means but i will
be explaining the data to you and we're
going to talk about that
on today's bonus show number two we are
going to
delve deeper into this idea of trump
doing rallies
um and rallies meant to raise money and
fire people up
for his legal challenges to the election
results is he really going to do it what
would be the effect
does does he have any reason not to do
it at this point in time that will be a
topic on today's
bonus show and we will also talk about
the movement of the stock market since
it became clear that joe biden would be
president of the united states and
there's actually people on the left that
are angry
so my view on this is we have a stock
market
and we have gdp and we have employment
and unemployment numbers
and we have job creation and we have
consumer confidence
given that these things exist and all
together they do tie to how well the
economy is doing
i want someone in office who's going to
see the better numbers and historically
it's been democrats
there are also people on the left who
say see the fact
that the stock market does better under
democrats
is evidence that democrats are even
worse corporatists than republicans
and democrats are actually bad now of
course that's extremely myopic because
all economic indicators do better under
democratic presidents so i want to talk
about that on the bonus show as well
if you have not yet heard the bonus show
or watched the bonus show i know we have
a lot of new viewers and listeners that
are here
because of the explosive growth of the
show
over the last 10 days the bonus show is
a daily extra show
for our members and patrons producer pat
the producer of the show
joins me on the bonus show i would love
for you
to join me as well two ways to do it
go to joinpakman.com and grab a
membership we have a new coupon code
fresh start why do we have a new coupon
code
the previous coupon code related to the
2020 election that election is done
we now are actually trying to take a
fresh start here
in the united states with joe biden and
maybe with the democratic senate
depending on what happens in georgia so
the coupon code fresh start
massive discount i won't even tell you
how big of a discount it is
because i'll have my lawyers beating
down the doors telling me no
it's too big of a discount but
sign up at jointpakman.com or make a
pledge at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and join me today on the
bonus show
we'll talk stocks and markets we'll talk
trump
rallies we'll talk polling pat actually
has some interesting stories from the
weekend as well he made a bunch of crank
calls some call them phony phone calls
to the trump voter fraud line
and he will tell us about it and i
actually have a lot more to discuss
related to that
i will see you then if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video